europe's vaccine rollout has been a
disappointment so far
the continent slow to authorize vaccines
in the first place and sluggish at
getting people injected
among many rows one focused on factories
like this
where vaccines are made in europe but
exported including
around 10 million doses that have gone
to the uk
today the european commission's
president went public threatening to
stop
exports to countries like britain where
many people
have already been vaccinated we are
exporting a lot
to countries that are themselves
producing vaccines
and we think this is an invitation to be
open
so that we also see experts from those
countries coming back
to the european union the bottom line is
that europe thinks it's been
short-changed by astrazeneca and here's
why
the european commission president said
that in the first three months of this
year both
pfizer born tech and moderna fulfilled
their contracts and delivered
66 million and 10 million doses
respectively to eu countries
she said despite initially being
promised a delivery of 90 million doses
astrazeneca had twice revised that
figure down
with now just a third of that original
number expected to be delivered by the
end of the month
mrs von deline said between april and
june fisa would deliver another
200 million doses to europe and moderna
another 35 million
she said a one-shot vaccine by johnson
johnson
would come on stream in april with 55
million doses
but she said that despite promising a
rollout of 180 million doses by the end
of june
astrazeneca had revised that delivery
figure down
to less than half so the threat is clear
if you don't supply us with more
vaccines made in britain then we'll cut
the supply of doses made in europe and
european leaders point out
that the uk has not exported any vaccine
doses so far
the reaction from the uk government an
era of shock that commitments to
open supply chains were now being eased
away we've all
been arguing for this um and we expect
those assurances and legal contracted
supply to be respected
frankly i'm surprised we're having this
conversation
is normally what the uk and the eu team
up with to object
when other countries uh with less
democratic regimes than our own
engage in that kind of brinkmanship the
irony is the european union's threat
comes at a time when most of its member
states
have paused use of the astrazeneca
vaccine
to investigate potential links to rare
blood clots in the brain
an announcement about that is expected
tomorrow but in countries like france
where
vaccine skepticism is already rife more
questions over safety really doesn't
help
europe's problems in dealing with this
covid crisis are obvious and they may be
about to get worse
in many countries the rate of infection
has now
gone up steeply in germany italy
and france and that probably means
more restrictions here in paris it may
well be
that we see another return to some kind
of lockdown
this is a city and a continent hobbled
by nervousness and uncertainty
about the disease the response and the
vaccine
adam parsons sky news paris